hello everybody my name is markiplier
and in this video I attempt to teach
Jack and Felix how to play World of
Warcraft but before I do that I had to
say a short little something because if
you didn't know about me I am and have
been for a long time a legitimate fan of
the Warcraft universe
I played World of Warcraft since it
first came out and I have sunk literally
thousands upon thousands of hours into
my life into that game but even before
that I was first introduced to Warcraft
because my dad bought it for me I can't
remember what year was but for Christmas
one year he bought me Warcraft 3 and
ever since then I was hooked on the
universe I loved the Warcraft universe
there was so much to it there was so
much juicing lore out of every pore it
was amazing and I I just ate it all up
and that's why I got so wrapped up in
world Warcraft and some of my best
memories from playing any sort of game
come from world of warcraft and playing
with my friends in my various guilds
that i play it throughout the years and
just having a good time exploring this
big beautiful universe so the reason i
say this is because the people behind
the warcraft movie they came to me and
they asked for my help to help promote
the movie and i am honestly and truly
legitimately excited for this i don't do
these sort of things unless I actually
like the thing that I'm promoting and in
this case I love the thing that I'm
promoting it's it's a rare occurrence
where I actually get to tell you guys
about something that I'm legitimately
passionate about and I am because I fell
in love with the entire universe and the
characters in this movie a lot of people
who have played World of Warcraft might
not know them I mean there's Khadgar in
this movie but this is like early
Khadgar in the most recent expansion you
see him when he's much older and much
more mature there's like Lothar which
not many people know about there's
Durotan which people may not know about
and there's gorona who's mentioned in
Wrath of the Lich King and may have been
mentioned at some other point in the
most recent expansion i didn't explore
every single nook and cranny so but
these characters like coming together
all doing like that i can't tell you
everything about the story or else i
would but i can't spoil anything but
it's just it's really cool to see
all this history that I have known for
years finally come to life in a movie
and you can say whatever you want about
a game versus a movie and whether a game
should be a movie in the first place but
what I know is that I love the story
behind Warcraft and throughout the
entirety of my time playing I have
almost never not loved finding out new
things about this universe I say almost
cuz I can't be overly like Joyce about
there's been ups and downs especially in
the world of warcraft time but honestly
and truly I'm excited about this movie
I'm excited to play this game with my
friends and to show them how I love the
game felix has played a bit but we'll
get to that you'll see in the video that
you're gonna see right now and I'll stop
rambling so you can get to that funny
stuff so how do we play the game oh you
guys don't know no we don't know
anything teach us wait wait we're gonna
sit and listen yeah you better get in
front of me better better pop down pop a
squat just mommy alright so here's the
Dino we're shooting off a lot of green
radiation at the moment and that means
do you want me to give you a lore lesson
on why we're irradiated yes please okay
sure why not a while ago I thought we
were farting butt--okay
yes we ate a lot of beans and we're
currently farting up a storm but years
ago in nombre gonne which is where we
are right now
there was an infestation of these
[ __ ] that had gangly arms and we're
basically stupid dickbags so the smart
people in charge decided to irradiate
the entirety of the city killing
everything and everyone where everyone
had to evacuate and now we're all
irradiated and we're being rescued Oh Oh
God
got it oh cool okay yeah that's very
good good explanation you know I know
you do your teacher dance you say yeah
you'll earn good deed and kitties right
now I'm a turn in the quest for us cuz
that's progress
we already closed our quest to kill
those all six of them Jesus Christ jack
are you not paying attention
No World of Warcraft teaching me world
war oh I'm teach I'm teaching you listen
up world Warcraft is a perpetual
exercise in murdering as many things as
possible you will literally travel the
world extinguishing all life in every
single area you go you will not get to
an area that you don't have to murder at
least a thousand creatures okay so it's
America simulator oh it's our land now
that's a complete American simulator
this is the most offensive episode of
world Warcraft in thanks carve oh you're
the best
yeah wait what how do you live a lot cuz
I'm better than he would barely be a
teacher I don't know what's better than
you so obviously I'd level up first
that's true I want a shot good those
guys have shot codes okay we have to
you're a warrior
alright so busy scream hang on shut up I
shut up you guys going to level 100 yeah
this is a bad idea
no it's not shut up it's fine it'll
guide us through the level honey we'll
be fine
sure this is going to go well dad
another day I see you boo P do P come to
mama come on mama go open your arms
daddy ah to axises mama daddy
dad mom are you that white dot I am yeah
how did you get that eye I mounted on it
i mouthed it you have it too jack yeah
you have it sweet where do i what look
at look at your toolbar you'll see
something that looks like an eagle with
armor on it click on that an eagle with
arm oh my god my friends
hi we look so [ __ ] cool oh oh you
have a magic carpet no that's not mine
that's somebody else that's some other
douchebag ok so we are together and we
are the new get the foo the [ __ ] is this
get the [ __ ] outta here
finally oh god I have like 50 [ __ ]
bags now uh-huh
that's good rice on my no cat hey I've
unspent Thailand poison what is
happening you'll never find me goddammit
I don't have any space [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
where you don't worry about it
there you are I see you I see you know
there you can't find me oh don't you
dare here you [ __ ] no priest
don't heal how dare you previous kill up
kill him kill the small one now one
which ones a small one that's the thing
I'm being I'm big it was kill kill die
as you kill I go he did it he didn't
kill my god I got an achievement that
said I killed you
I got BAM baby ah delicious hurts me
challenge me to a duel you'll serve two
three two one go hit me kill him ah I'm
just messing all my [ __ ] those are my
boys
those are my buddy boos oh if you want a
sub or even having a Griffin okay if you
want to fly and how cool we can go back
to the mainland and just lie there I
think we should get alright follow me
above my head and Phoenix has a moon I
put him there just so we can distinguish
who is who and we're going to storm win
because that's closest we're going to go
to stormy can we go to go look up to
gold Shire oh my god yes we will do it
if if you got okay alright but just
follow me the mountains right over here
you get to fly over see all the cool
vistas this is where the movies gonna
take place you remember in the trailer
you saw the fly Oh every blah blah I
want to see that I don't know much about
Warcraft so I want to know as much as
possible before the movie well this is
Stormwind
it's where the humans live humans that's
all I know about it okay the burning
steps I remember this place yeah exactly
look totally [ __ ] the nostalgia yeah
there's no statues
no right of the statue I got 60 yeah III
at 60 here too cuz I was just grinding
ogres like endless ogre yogurts mine
tonio get so many ogres my god you
[ __ ] those yeah those ochres am i
right hey [ __ ] you those ogres were an
ordeal you'll never understand it took
days days the game 59 to 60 day I seek D
Lee wants to get your first mount yeah
five Shawn I had I had to borrow gold
from one of my guild mates to get enough
that I never paid him back I'm such an
ass second man here's where things get
complicated because this actually takes
some strategy seeing the big blue stream
up there and the orb on the left that
that orc is touching one of us has to
touch that orb and then control that
dragon on the right his name is razor
gore you can hear that only dragon you
do not want to let razor Gore die that's
the point
razor Gore can't die or else we die
so what razor Gore does is razor Gore
goes around and he I think he destroys
the eggs I may be completely wrong about
it's been years like what are we - and
can we just kill things now yes what
will happen is I'll get the oh god oh
god what the [ __ ] did you do you crazy
Irish game we're doing it I'll touch
your okay see I got a razor Gore right
here so now I can destroy the eggs Oh
what do we do do we protect him yeah you
protect me there's going to be things
coming around there's gonna be lots and
lots of eggs dude no no no no no no I'm
blowing eggs up I'm blowing open
everywhere no I'm not picking open Oh
poop you can literally do this on your
own with them constantly attacking you
and you would never die probably okay
but um they're all dead okay so now now
we kill razor gore I think no no nobody
have 200 dead oh I'm really need on
everything oh yeah [ __ ] you I'm rolling
need on everything yeah my epic loot
yeah it's so [ __ ] now this this
encounter was really cool because um it
was it was our friend
there's lore behind this this was our
friend but he was just corrupted and
it's like a race you have to kill him so
quickly but we all get this buff that
makes us super awesome but we're kind of
super awesome anyway so he's gonna die
in two hits but the whole thing was we
had to like this was an endeavor you
needed five tanks and you needed to
rotate off of tanks because each tank
would blow up like you would die it was
amazing oh yeah the times would blow up
yeah exactly so you had to rotate five
tanks they all had to stack their threat
levels you had to manage threat which is
something that doesn't happen anymore
which is really stupid like I liked it
back then when that was actually a thing
you don't have to do that no not anymore
right now in the game it's like a tank
has threat indefinitely there's no
struggle to it you know that was the
time I know why I should be BAM okay
hey it's more epically yes because he
don't ever get no I'm I don't even it I
mean it yeah yeah yeah I got about I got
I got nothing way mark yeah why does my
character I changed when I changed yet
did they seriously look the same are you
[ __ ] kidding like this is how these
epic [ __ ] shoulder pads look like are
you no no thanks let me see no that's it
I have no those look like a city why you
look like such [ __ ] yeah I got an epic
oh wait my shoulder shoulder pads was
like the only other cool in the game
yeah and those are just a bag of asses
but now oh man that's the thing like
they spent so much time on making things
look cool that they they took away the
idea of I shouldn't criticize we're not
supposed to criticize it so I want to
hear you're saying no what I'm saying is
that they emphasize so much I'm making
things look cool and making sure that
everybody could get the cool thing but
that Rob is the specialness of getting
that cool thing when everyone can get it
you know what I mean
like things aren't exclusive anymore
things aren't special and it's I
understand the accessibility factor but
there's something to have something to
work that no one else could have yeah a
goal like a big thing that's unreachable
and then the people that get them become
legends on your server alright I know
what you mean
Felix where you uh-uh middle weight you
wait for the dragon you get the final
blow in the act all tanked night
a rogue tank evasion tank a problem yeah
god I remember they're funny yeah the
last desperation to Jack what would
happen like if all the tank guy
unusually and if it's cool yeah if all
the tanks die usually the Rogues were
the next highest on the threat meters so
they have this ability called evasion
that gives them 100 percent dodge chance
for like eight seconds yeah you have
eight seconds so it's like a rogue tank
go and then pet tanks and then like
desperation tactics it was so funny
is everyone making a girl no hahaha
making himself make it hot yeah ah oh
yeah free booze hey good God my thighs I
could crush this [ __ ] wolf with my
thighs another they do ill oh we have a
good time
hey you know I do look at my epic Amish
beard can you deflect my arrows with
your pegs can I can deflect him with my
balls rod if you'd like Jack what are
you doing take off your clothes
fine fine that'll right into your
character menu and drag amoxicillin ah
learning with me you just take off your
pants I'll leave this shirt off your
pants that's all it is
free guys hearing over here oh my god
guys flirting with me oh my god oh my
god what is happening he's so shirtless
six we made very similar character Lu
what about maybe yeah is it any room for
duel well what's our dance like yeah
and Janna all right what happens in the
end stays in the oh um yeah welcome to
the end guys oh yeah you like it
ah I'm scare out right now this is a
very interesting place guys yeah welcome
uh just feel free have a drink
take off your pants have a good time
hands have been off for a while now
oh okay I'll take mine no I'm leaving my
pants on you don't want to see the
disaster area that is my grundle come on
don't be such a pest a will find that
jeez see I warned you take off them
pants I haven't shaved in a while ah
you've unleashed the Beast